Speaker 1: . OK, so Donald Trump had another
one of these rallies that he has restarted
over the Fourth of July weekend.
I covered it live.
And tomorrow, actually, hopefully later today,
I'm going to lay out what I think will happen
if Donald Trump does indeed run in twenty,
twenty four.
I happen to think that Joe and Carmela are
in real trouble if Trump runs in four.
I know that there are some in the audience
who disagree with me and some that vehemently,
vehemently disagree.
We'll get to that later.
But in terms of the rallies themselves, they're
truly horrifying.
I mean, every time I cover one of these rallies,
I get dozens of emails, especially from foreign
viewers, saying, David, what is happening
in the United States?
These rallies are dangerous.
This one was in Florida.
Trump admitting to crimes during them, by
the way.
We'll get to that, of course, telling completely
corrosive, easily debunked lies about American
democracy.
And the crowd.
It it's it's not even notable to say the crowd
believes it.
There is not even the possibility that the
crowd might question anything they're told
at these rallies.
And that's very scary.
Does the crowd have what we would call an
illness?
I'm increasingly unsure what we even call
what these folks are suffering from.
So let's just start with Trump confessing
to crimes during the speech.
Trump's business, his organization and Trump's
CFO, Alan Weiss Weisberg, have been indicted.
Part of these charges relate to allegedly
avoiding taxes by having Donald Trump directly
pay for stuff for his CFO over a 15 year period.
Tons of stuff, tons of money.
And Trump admits even if only to part of the
stuff saying not paying taxes on your company
car or your grandkids education.
The allegation is Trump would directly pay
for Weisberg's grandkids educations, which
really should be income.
Weissenberg pays taxon and he's accused of
not paying tax on that.
That's what they're accused of in Trump's
admitting it.
Here, take a look at this.
Speaker 2: And yet they go after good, hardworking
people for not paying taxes on a company car
company.
You didn't pay tax on the car or a company
apartment.
You used an apartment because you need an
apartment because you have to travel too far
with your houses and didn't pay tax or education
for your grandchildren.
I don't even know.
Do you have to pay?
Does anybody know the answer to that stuff?
Speaker 1: OK, so Trump admitting to it and
the crowd barely has any idea what Trump is
even talking about.
But Trump is confessing to the crimes that
they have been charged with in this case.
This actually helps him and his followers
if he just admits to it in public.
This is has been a strategy for a long time.
You admit to it in public.
Trump says it definitely shouldn't be illegal.
The fact that there is a law against this
is me being a victim of something and his
followers just get on his side 110 percent,
even though he's admitting to crimes when
others say, listen, OK, drugs, fine, but that
really shouldn't be a crime, these law and
order right wingers say.
But it is.
And law and order means if something's a crime,
you have to be punished for it.
When Trump says, is this stuff even a crime?
It shouldn't be a crime, then they're with
him 100 percent.
And Trump even pointing out during this speech
the strategy that he uses.
If you keep repeating lies to your followers,
your followers will start to believe them.
Trump talks about it as if it's applicable
to Democrats, but it's actually exactly what
he does.
Take a look at this
Speaker 2: all of a sudden.
They said today, I heard and there's a word
disinformation.
It's called this.
If you say it enough and keep saying it just
keeps it, they'll start to believe you.
We can't let that happen because now they're
saying the Republicans wanted to defund the
police.
I said, you know,
Speaker 1: this is why half or more of Trump's
followers still to this day believe that he
won.
The 2020 election, because Trump and others
keep repeating it, Trump then paints himself
as a victim, if you can believe it, and he
brings up Hillary Clinton.
Yeah, it's 21.
We're halfway through 20, 21.
He's bringing up Hillary Clinton stuff from
2015.
And earlier, look at this
Speaker 2: from Ukraine, from China.
They didn't go after Hillary Clinton and her
foundation.
They didn't touch her.
They leave Democrats alone no matter how bad
they are.
But they mobilize every power of government
to come after me, my family, my wonderful
employees and my company solely because of
politics.
Speaker 1: So Trump, as usual, the biggest
victim of anybody.
You'll see later in the show, his children
also painting themselves as just the perpetual,
endless victims.
Now, then it goes totally off the rails.
Trump gets back on the statue's stuff and
he claims without any evidence that Democrats
want to replace the Jefferson Memorial with
a statue of Al Sharpton, which is baseless.
First of all, it strikes me as probably racist
in some way, although I'm I'm trying to figure
out exactly all of the ways in which it is.
Take a look at this clip
Speaker 2: and they want to take the statue
of Thomas Jefferson out and replace it with
somebody.
By the way, let me tell you, you're not going
to be happy with the person they want to replace
him with.
Ladies and gentlemen, Thomas Jefferson is
being removed from the Jefferson Memorial
and being replaced with the Reverend Al Sharpton.
I don't think so,
Speaker 1: so it's also really stupid, I mean,
I wouldn't want an Al Sharpton statue replacing
the Jefferson Memorial and I'm on the left,
so it's just like layers upon layers of dumb
gaslighting.
And then, of course, no Trump rally is complete
without the slurring part of the evening.
I won't spend a lot of time on this.
The speech went nearly two hours, clearly
way too long for Trump.
And as the sweat poured, the slurring ramped
up.
Here's Trump saying that our ancestors crust,
they crust fascism.
Speaker 2: Take a look at our ancestors crust
just absolutely crushed fascism beneath the
weight.
Speaker 1: So an absolutely absurd event.
These apparently are going to continue.
I think that this is part of Trump's plan
to build himself up and build up his influence
going into 2022.
And because you don't normally I won't talk
about an election that's not the next one.
But I'm actually going to break my own rule
later on in today's show, because what Trump
is doing now is as much about 2024 as it is
about twenty two.
And you really can't talk about one without
talking about the other.
So I'm going to talk about that a little bit
later.
But next, what I want to go to is to show
you some interviews with Trump supporters
that went to this rally in Sarasota, Florida,
which is arguably even scarier than than the
things Trump said himself.
So let's
get
to
that next.